so first of all this is an ongoing
investigation and uh so i i can't
comment on the on the details or or
exactly what type of uh incident it was
what type of crime it may have been
but it does look as though the taxi
driver in question did behave uh with
incredible presence of mind and and
bravery but i've got to say this is
something that is a is an ongoing
investigation i think it'd be premature
to say much more than that could
christmas be in danger if we don't get
jabs boosters to younger people
i think it's very good news that the the
jcvi has today authorized the uh the
booster program to be rolled out to
everybody 40 plus and when you look at
what's happening in the in the pandemic
at the moment it's just here in in
newham
sadly there are people in in itu in
intensive care who are
who are suffering badly from from kobe
but they're all the unvaccinated and
what's happening is that if you can get
your your booster then your immunity
goes right back up to 95
so far we've got 75
of everybody over
getting a booster there's a huge number
of people but we it's it's that further
that will make all the difference to the
winter to to christmas to to our plans
uh going forward because it's that extra
level of protection that we really need
so the message is uh anybody
over
uh 70 come forward get your business
anybody over 50 come forward and get
your booster and now
in the next uh week or so anybody over
40 as well come forward and get your
booster and we're also
doing a second dose for the 16 and 17
year olds
last year you last minute had to
introduce restrictions at christmas
if we don't see people come forward for
this we don't get younger people these
for this protection could we see
restrictions again do you think we don't
see anything in the data at the moment
to suggest that we need to to go to plan
b you know we're gonna we're sticking
with with plan a but what we certainly
have got to to recognize is there is a
storm of infection out there in parts of
of europe you can see those numbers uh
uh ticking up very sharply in in so some
of our continental friends
and we've just got to recognize that uh
there is always a risk that a blizzard
could come
from the east again as the months get
colder the best protection uh for our
country is for everybody to go forward
and get their booster we'll see a vote
today in the comments to row back on the
patterson vote you said yesterday that
you wish you'd handle things differently
is now the time to finally apologize for
your error of judgment and i i just want
to salute uh you and the the the media
generally for keeping going on this
subject i'm here to talk about boosters
and are ready to urge people to come
forward and get their boosters that's
the the critical thing we've seen the
transport secretary grant chaps of
reports about him over the weekend were
you aware that he'd set up a
group to lobby against house building on
airfields
again
i've got nothing to add on on that if
there are things to be investigated then
that of course that should uh that
should take place but i i admire the way
that you're keeping going the key thing
is uh today uh people should should
think about their booster program
about getting a booster as you've said
uh i think it is the only real
risk that we face that we don't get
enough people coming forward the numbers
are starting to climb it's it's it's
incredibly exciting we've got 12.6
million boosters already done uh that i
think that we're closing the gap between
those that uh we've done and those that
are eligible which is so the program
that's accelerating and the i want to
thank gps for what they're doing i don't
think we paid we've paid enough tribute
to uh to gps and gp surgeries and all
the staff
for the way they are now doing huge
numbers of boosters and it's making a
big big difference final question you
say people want to talk about voters of
course they do but people do care about
this stuff do you not think it's time
for you as the prime minister to show
leadership here and say i got this wrong
i'm sorry i i've i again i might want
you so i said something about that last
night and uh what i think we want to do
is encourage people to to get their
boosters